One of the most controversial and often maligned
mechanics anywhere in the commander format is
Eminence. Eminence is a keyword officially on five
legendary creatures and unofficially on a sixth,
and its effect is simple—it lets one line of
text on a commander also work while the card
is in the command zone. So, Sidar Jabari of
Zhalfir’s first line of text allows you to
loot—to draw and then discard—whenever you
attack with one or more knights, and this
happens regardless of whether he himself is on
the battlefield or in the command zone. Then,
he has another line of text that only applies
while he’s on the field and plays off the eminence
line—reanimating a Knight creature whenever he
deals combat damage to an opponent. This is how
all 6 of the Eminence creatures work—there will
be the eminence ability that helps the deck a
bit earlier in the game, and then the commander
will be a sort of followup to that once played,
amplifying the advantage gained by the
eminence ability. If you’re somebody who’s
totally new to the keyword, this could seem like
a pretty reasonable sort of ability structure,
a relatively unobjectionable way for a
commander to be designed. And, in this video,
I’m going to argue just that—mostly. Eminence
is a largely fine keyword that I would like to
see again in some form, and its bad reputation
is primarily due to some questionable design
decisions on Wizards of the Coast’s part when
they designed some of the original eminence cards.
There are a lot of places I could start my
daring defense, but I’m going to start with
two interesting things that happened this year.
In May, Atraxa Praetors’ Voice lost her position
as the most popular commander. Then, last
month, she lost her position as the second
most popular commander as well. What replaced her
was The Ur Dragon and Edgar Markov, both with the
keyword “eminence”. If you’re unfamiliar with
these, you’re probably asking, what could these
commanders do to make them this popular? And,
let’s start there. Edgar Markov’s eminence ability
reads “Whenever you cast another vampire spell,
create a 1/1 black vampire creature token.” More
mid-powered Edgar decks will typically run a wide
range of different mana values and enjoy the extra
vampire every turn or two, whereas higher-powered
Edgar decks will blast the table with an endless
wave of low-cost vampires to take advantage of
the complete lack of any restrictions on Eddie’s
eminence ability, as well as the plentiful
go-wide payoffs Mardu vampires has access to.
Edgar the playable creature is a 6 mana 4/4
with first strike and haste that gives all your
vampires a +1/+1 counter when he attacks. Not a
bad effect, but certainly not something most Edgar
players will be rushing to spend 6 mana to get.
What about the Ur Dragon, the current most popular
commander? His eminence ability simply reads
“your other dragon spells cost 1 less to cast.”
Unlike Edgar Markov, The Ur-Dragon’s creature
form is quite good if you have the mana for it,
with him being a 9 mana 10/10 flier with the
ability “Whenever one or more dragons you control
attack, draw that many cards, then you may put
a permanent card from your hand onto the field.”
This collective package doesn’t require much
explanation—the Eminence ability is a powerful
mana discount for dragons and the field ability is
a powerful value engine with dragons, collectively
producing the two primordial resources for
generically-playing-the-game as a dragon deck.
So these are our two most popular commanders
at present day. They’re also controversial and
disliked by a lot of players, particularly
Edgar Markov. I am among those players,
and I don’t think either of these cards should
have been printed in the form they were. However,
the reasons why these cards are seen as
problematic by me and some other players
are complicated and have layers to them. The
simplest answer is because they’re powerful,
and I actually would consider this a major
feature in what makes these cards problematic.
However, power alone doesn’t make a commander
an issue. Sisay, Weatherlight Captain is one
of the most powerful commanders in the game,
but I don’t think most people would consider
her any sort of problem. She operates in a
unique way and within a niche that has other
good options for players who want a different
playstyle, and her cEDH variants don’t tend to
bleed play patterns into casual in the same way
some other commanders do. So what makes these
weaker commanders more of an issue by comparison?
One of these is simple—being associated with an
iconic creature type imbues them with a natural
casual commander aura—a tutor engine like Sisay
obviously feels weird at a table of precons,
but that big ol’ dragon deck might pass the vibe
check just fine. This is the classic feature of a
pubstomper commander—not strictly being powerful,
but being out of place, easily wriggling its
way into games it might not really belong in.
Another power-associated issue I’d identify
with these is something I alluded to when I was
talking about Sisay earlier—these two crowd
other commanders out of lanes. Dragons and
vampires are two of the most iconic Magic: the
Gathering creature types, and they’re naturally
going to be popular choices for players new
to the commander format. The issue, then,
is that both of these commanders ended up being by
far the strongest option for their creature type,
and that fact then pushed any new Dragon
or Vampire player looking for a shortcut
to a strong deck to get there by paying
a lot of money for the singular strongest
commander. Edgar Markov spent over four
years above the $50 mark and the Ur Dragon
spent two of those years at a similar price,
with both of their peak periods corresponding
with the surge in the popularity of the
commander format that started in late 2020.
Initially, the connection with eminence might
seem pretty surface level—a powerful eminence
card takes over a creature type, and a weaker
eminence card might not do this. But this misses
a key feature, which is how eminence interacts
with colors. See, the Ur-Dragon’s color identity
is part of its issue—if Ur Dragon had the same
eminence text but was mono red or even red blue,
suddenly that’s an actual niche. Bladewing
could have stayed the red black choice,
Atarka could have stayed the red green choice,
and the ever-funky Scion of the Ur Dragon could
have stayed the choice for players
who really wanted all five colors.
But, if you instead make a 5 color option
that’s dramatically better than the others,
and if that power doesn’t even require casting
the card, you destroy a lot of the reason to
consider other options. Even if you don’t
want to play with a five color manabase,
the discount alone makes Ur-Dragon already better
than most of the other options even if it’s
never cast. The same goes for Edgar—vampires are
traditionally mono black, followed by black red,
followed by black white. If Edgar had been
put in the relatively-unexplored-in-2017 color
identity of black white, suddenly vampire
players would have a choice between the more
established vampire identity of black red and
the newer, Ixalan-centered identity of black
white with this spicy new commander. Instead,
both of these are slurped up by Edgar, and the
fact that most of his power is in his eminence
ability means that players don’t even need to
try to be in three colors—just stick him at the
head of your red black vampire deck and cast him
when you draw your command tower, and bing bang
boom, your deck just received a strict upgrade.
To be clear, I don’t think it’s wrong for
Wizards of the Coast to have wanted big
powerful uniting options with lots of colors
to hand to some iconic creature types. However,
Eminence has some unique problems in fitting this
role, and for this reason that I would lean toward
two colors or less on eminence commanders as
a rule, especially if they’re in a niche where
they risk overshadowing other options. I also
might have done this with the more recently
printed Sidar Jabari of Zhalfir which works with
Knights, though at least that one has a better
balance between the power of the eminence ability
and the power of the castable creature. Now,
it might sound like this “niche” element—being
tied to iconic creature types—is a big part of
my problem with Edgar and the Ur Dragon. And,
in a sense it is, but tying eminence cards to
a creature type actually accomplishes an
important goal—increasing the specificity
of eminence abilities. See, having an effect
baked into your gameplay for free is pretty
potent. Some players might find it inherently
problematic, and my personal opinion is that
those players are underestimating the sheer power
that a traditional command zone can offer a deck,
but still. Getting an effect without paying for
it is certainly notable, and it’s important that
this effect is specific so as to contain how
out of hand it can get. This is true for both
the trigger of the eminence ability and the
payoff for it—ideally it should be a specific
trigger that provides a specific output, but
if you’re going to make one a bit more general,
you really need to be careful to crank up the
specificity of the other. Let’s take the example
of an eminence ability that gets this right
in my book: that of Arahbo, Roar of the World.
On paper this ability is by no means weak—giving
+3/+3 to a creature every combat step from the
very first turn of the game is quite powerful,
allowing for some hefty beatdown early and
amplifying later damage done with various effects
that play off of damage dealt. However, this
effect, in addition to typically falling under
the generally less problematic aggro archetype,
is specific. It’s an effect that makes a cat
more powerful at attacking. There’s a couple
double strike cats and a singular infect
cat that will offer the occasional early
kill on a blockerless opponent, but with the cat
limitation you don’t have access to a whole lot
of cards that would be powerful if they were a
lot bigger on an early turn. This specificity
counterintuitively has a diversifying effect
on the play patterns of Arahbo decks—rather
than being all-in on taking advantage of the +3/+3
buff on turns 2-4 when it’s the most powerful,
Arahbo players need to devise ways to make use of
the effect more holistically throughout the game,
and this can take a variety of different forms.
Arahbo’s eminence is also uniquely interactable
among eminence commanders—a sorcery-speed +3/+3
pump doesn’t typically do anything until creatures
are making contact during combat, which leaves
ample opportunity to interact with it. I like
this design for Arahbo, but you may have noticed
that I did say “uniquely interactable”. All other
Eminence abilities are easier to get value with,
with Sidar Jabari only requiring attacking with
knights, Inalla only requiring Wizards to enter,
and the other three being almost entirely
impossible to stop the effects of. This
un-interactibility is another point of critique
that you’ll most commonly find from the removal
lovers of the world—these commanders all
have effects that can’t even be gotten rid
of by dusting them with Swords to Plowshares.
Now, I’ll lay my cards on the table here and
say that in principle this feature of Eminence
doesn’t strictly bother me. There are lots of
things that can’t be interacted with barring hard
stax pieces—drawing a card at the start of turn,
playing lands, untapping permanents, and so forth.
This game is also full of hexproof creatures,
uncounterable spells, and abilities that can’t
even be responded to. Setting these more specific
examples aside, it’s also important to remember
that deleting opposing stuff doesn’t need to be
the end-all-be-all of EDH, and I find that this
intense focus on spot removal tends to indicate
a lack of creativity from players. A couple
months ago I discussed on a 2nd channel video
that I actually enjoy not having many tools to
deal with very large creatures in one of my decks,
as it forces me to think harder with my attacks
and utilize the deck’s more aggressive tools in
some situations. This is a game with many
axes on which to attack opposing resources,
whether that be board, hand, library, life
total, or the stack, and it’s good to be
willing to move outside your comfort zone
sometimes among those different options.
Now, does all of this mean that the
un-interactability of Eminence creatures is
never a problem? No, and in practice this feature
of eminence can be a real pain point for players,
with Edgar Markov being one of the more egregious
examples of an eminence ability feeling bad due
to its un-interactibility. His eminence ability
triggers on-cast for a card type with a lot of
great low-cost options, any number of times per
turn. If I’m at a low life total and I counter two
vampire spells that the Edgar player plays, they
still get the two tokens. If they have a source
of haste—Edgar is in red, remember—these vampires
can attack immediately. And these easy-to-obtain
and hard-to-prevent 1/1s aren’t just creatures
to attack and block with. Vampires as a type
have a bunch of really powerful cards that take
advantage of the raw number of vampires in play,
most of which can only be prevented with a
counterspell, and that’s to say nothing of
the Blood Artists and other aristocrat tools
that powerful Eddie decks tend to be crammed
with. An eminence ability that grants creature
tokens for casting spells was always going to
be a little tricky to pull off regardless
of creature type, and that ability being
for vampires in a deck with black puts fully
over the line into dangerous territory—the
tokens are too easy to get, and there’s
too many things that can be done with them.
In this extended discussion of how Edgar
plays, the point I’m trying to make is
that the frustrating play patterns of him and
some other Eminence commanders are the result
of specific design choices, not a problem with
the eminence mechanic as a whole. Gavin Verhey,
who worked on the design for Edgar Markov and
other eminence cards, has said that future
Eminence designs should avoid generating permanent
on-board material for players. I personally would
set a similar but somewhat broader rule—the
difficulty and specificity of the setup needs
to match the power of the payoff. If triggering
an eminence ability is easy, the payoff should
be less generic and require more ingenuity to
take advantage of, as is the case with Oloro,
and to a lesser extent Inalla. If an eminence
ability has a stronger and more generic payoff,
it should have a triggering condition
that is more specific or more preventable,
as is true of Arahbo. When in doubt, designers
should go more specific with both of these things.
Relating back to Gavin’s view, giving players
something like a creature token or a treasure
token is an exceptionally generic payoff,
and engineering a condition that’s adequately
specific to avoid the card feeling frustrating
or uninteractible is going to be a big challenge.
I also choose a broader rule here because
I think The Ur Dragon is an example of
frustratingly uninteractible design as well,
though to a lesser extent than Edgar. Mana is
one of the two primordial resources of Magic: the
Gathering, and discounting creatures is equivalent
to giving players an Eldrazi Scion worth of
mana to spend every time they’d want to cast
one of those creatures. The Medallion cycle,
which each discount spells of a given color,
are some of the most powerful 2 mana artifacts
in the game, and The Ur-Dragon puts a roughly
equivalent discount in the command zone. So, a
Dragon deck can get an entirely impossible to
stop accelerant to their gameplan, and the rest
of the table can only do their best to deal with
the results of that acceleration. This can pose
a problem for players having fun in the here and
now, but the much larger problem is with what it
does to the design space of the game, and this
is another thing that comes up in the Commander
Chronicles episode. Dragons might cost a lot now,
but making a card type all cost 1 less straight
from the command zone with no restrictions means
that any low-cost cards of that type in the
future that include any colorless are going to
have an outsized impact on Ur-Dragon decks. WotC
has kind of fully committed to being careful with
this specifically with dragons since they also
recently printed Mox Jasper, but in general it’s
a bit reckless to alter future design space this
way with a type as frequently printed as dragons.
The design rule I’d set here is simple—eminence
abilities should not directly give cards or mana.
Indirectly is fine—all of the eminence commander
abilities are frequently used to generate cards,
mana, or both in their respective decks, but there
needs to be an extra step involved to increase
the specificity and interactivity of this sort of
ability. Accumulating these primordial resources
is a massive part of most commander decks,
and giving a deck these resources totally for
free with no extra steps gets you into really
dangerous territory for a deck feeling healthy
and fitting in. The Ur Dragon is considered a
classic pub-stomper commander because it plays
durdly battlecruiser magic in principle, but
its design is streamlined to simply do that
better than just about any other deck can, and
effortlessly receiving mana is a big part of that.
We can also see this echoed in partner
commanders. Of the 5 partner commanders
that see the most competitive EDH play,
4 of them directly give cards or mana,
and the 5th is used indirectly with other cards
to grant cards and mana. This is especially the
case with partners because the mechanic
inherently grants card advantage, but this
is just an amplification of a general trend. Of
these 5, the top two are both two-color cards,
because color is yet another modulating factor
that determines the power of a command zone.
More colors means more access to powerful tools
and more access to powerful resources engines,
and while these are most seen in cEDH, these
effects of course bleed into casual as well.
If we look at the three most popular commanders
of the past year, it’s an easy to trigger card
draw engine, another easy to trigger card draw
engine, and a massive mana-granter. This is not
to say that these designs are bad, or that it’s
never okay to print cards with mana symbols or
the words draw or land on them. It’s simply a
reflection that WotC should be, and probably
already knows to be, a little extra careful
when it comes to printing things that give
direct resources aimed at commander players,
whether Eminence is involved or otherwise.
So, Eminence. Should it really be reprinted? My
answer is yes, because I think the design space is
interesting. The command zone is the most unique
part about the commander format, and its quirks
and whose weird little nooks and crannies of
possibility are endlessly fascinating to me. It’s
for this same reason that I sometimes find myself
drawn to the Partner mechanic as well, despite
disliking it on a conceptual level, and Eminence
is a far more interesting set of nooks to be
explored further. There are some strategies that
just aren’t as powerful in commander, and it’s
nice to be able to print a card that gives them a
boost without needing to fit the restrictions of
a conventional commander. There are also lots of
interesting design possibilities that don’t work
without an element that operates with a commander
in the command zone, ripe design territory for
exploration. So, for the rest of this video I want
to think about some eminence designs that make
cool usage of the mechanic while avoiding most of
the elements that other people find problematic.
Earlier in this video I’ve gone through three
rules I’d follow when designing Eminence
cards—stick to two colors or less if there’s
any risk of competing with existing commanders,
aim for higher specificity if there’s any power
concern, and avoid any eminence effect that
directly creates card or mana advantage. I’ll
also add a fourth one here that I didn’t cover
earlier—Eminence commanders should be desirable
to actually cast. The two biggest offenders here
are the aforementioned Edgar Markov, as well as
one I haven’t talked about as much—Inalla. The
issue with both of these is that the text on the
creature just isn’t that great of an amplification
of the eminence effect. There are an endless list
of better things you could do with 1/1 vampires
for 6 mana than putting a +1/+1 counter on them,
and tapping Wizards to drain opponents is an even
worse amplification on Inalla’s value-crunching,
ETB-focused eminence ability. So that’ll be our
final rule—it needs to be desirable to cast
the creature. This is the commander format,
so you should be casting your commander! Not
casting an eminence commander also betrays
the purpose of the mechanic a bit to me as
well—it gives an opportunity for the command
zone to offer multiple tiers of benefit, one
before your commander is in play and one after,
but this can’t happen if you never have a
reason to ascend past the first tier of power.
So we have our rules, but what would I do with
the Eminence mechanic? I mentioned Aggro a bit
earlier, and that’s actually the biggest area of
opportunity I personally see for eminence. See,
aggro is actually challenging on a structural
level with regard to commanders themselves.
There are a bunch of fast deck styles that are
only propped up by the presence of a somewhat
fragile commander, leading to glass cannon decks
that are capable of crushing players but fall
apart to two removal spells. The commander
allows the deck to attain a high ceiling,
but the floor of the deck typically looks
pathetic in the landscape of a 3 opponent,
40 life format, leading to a somewhat jarring play
pattern. What eminence does, then, is allow you to
split the difference, with the eminence effect
boosting a deck’s early game and overall floor,
and the commander creature offering a way to
compound that advantage in order to keep up a
bit later in the game. Arahbo is one example, but
here’s another that I came up with with a similar
ability format—instead of a conventional voltron
commander you dump all your resources onto,
how about an Eminence ability that reads
“At the beginning of combat on your turn,
you may choose a creature you control. If you
do, put a +1/+1 counter on it for each equipment
attached to it.” Then the creature itself could
be Storg, a 5 mana red black human soldier with
the text “Whenever you attack, you may have
target attacking creature you control deal
damage equal to its power to any target. If seven
or more damage is dealt this way, draw a card.”
The eminence effect here can kick in early with
keywords like Living Weapon and For Mirrodin,
and it also works well alongside especially
low-slung equipment bearers like Goblin Gaveleer
or Moria Marauder. This allows the deck to start
putting on pressure pretty early into the game,
and encourages devoting more deck space to
low-cost stuff that might traditionally scale
poorly in the landscape of EDH. The creature
itself serves as a followup piece that amplifies
this once the deck reaches 5 mana, effectively
amplifying the damage of the presumably equipped
and buffed largest attacker and gaining card draw
if that source of damage was especially large.
You could also construct something spicier more
along the lines of a Torbran or a Solphim. How
about an eminence effect that reads “the first
time a source you control deals noncombat damage
to a single permanent or player each turn, it
deals that much damage plus one instead.” Or,
power it up and give it a condition: “as long as
you have permanents of at least four different
types, whenever a source you control would deal
noncombat damage, it deals that much damage plus
one instead.” Ends up a little wordy once you
add the eminence clause, but you get the idea.
For both this last example and the example
of Storg’s equipment-based eminence ability,
care has been put into making these abilities
feel interactible. Multiple permanents are
required to be in play in order for the effect
to trigger, unlike 4 of the 6 original eminence
commanders whose ability is on a cast trigger, an
ETB trigger, or an upkeep trigger. Sure, you still
can’t remove the source of the effect with these
ideas, but there are certainly steps required to
get the benefit from it, and steps your opponents
can take to deny you that value. These also both
fall off big time if you don’t cast the commander.
1 extra conditional damage isn’t that great,
and a handful of +1/+1 counters each turn that
you have to work for, and which prevent you
from using one of the much better equipment
commanders out there, also isn’t that great.
Aggro is the biggest area that I like personally
as a way to utilize eminence due to the mechanic’s
early-game emphasis and stair-steppy nature, but
that’s far from the only cool use case for it.
There’s a lot of other interesting design niches
to be explored, and 3/3 Elk showed me a handful
of custom cards they’d made to demonstrate them.
You could have an eminence ability offer a less
concrete resource such as goad, and then have
the commander itself give a way to more tangibly
capitalize on goaded creatures. You could have
an eminence ability that accumulates resources
in some way, but with those resources only being
accessible by keeping the actual card in play,
sort of like a riff on experience counters
that’s more stable and less swingy.
You could also have an eminence ability that’s
actually a downside, with a strong commander that
mitigates that downside, allowing for some truly
unique designs and play patterns. Alternatively,
you could even have a Breena-style politics-y
eminence ability that can help any player,
with the attached commander creature allowing a
player to break parity and amplify the benefit
they gain from it. All of these show the potential
of the mechanic—it doesn’t have to be just a
powerful boost to a creature type with an optional
attached creature. All sorts of cool and elegant
designs are possible here, and attaining them
requires, above all else, mindset and restraint.
I believe the Ur Dragon and Edgar Markov were each
made with the idea for them to be a super cool
powerful perfectly-rounded commander for players
who like the extremely popular tribes of Dragons
and Vampires, respectively. This is how you create
the two most popular commanders of all time,
and in the process create cards that have each
commanded triple digit price tags for multiple
month spans since the time they were released.
I also believe these cards were mistakes,
but that’s because crowning a powerful color-soup
champion for two popular and iconic creature types
while simultaneously introducing a spicy new
command zone modification was an inherently
challenging task, and one that just so happened to
be a poor pairing for reasons I laid out earlier.
A lot of people have called eminence itself
a mistake or a bad mechanic, and those people
are half-correct—eminence is a mechanic that is
challenging to implement well, and which carries
the full possibility to easily veer off course
and into problems. But importantly, that’s only
because the mechanic poses such a fundamental
shakeup to the structure of the command zone,
and that feature of it also imbues it with a ton
of rich gameplay possibilities. One of the most
restrictive things about the commander format is
that decks often feel “on” or “off”—either their
commander is in play, or it isn’t. The eminence
mechanic offers the ability to bypass that,
to add massive layers of dimension to commanders,
particularly ones that are more aggressive. That’s
an incredible tool, and it’s one I’d love
to see used again, with care, in the future.
With that said, thanks for watching, and thanks
to Archidekt for supporting the channel. When
I’m building decks with Archidekt, I can easily
add cards directly into any of my categories,
including one of my mainboard categories.
If you want to check out my decks,
a link is in the description. I’d
also like to thank my supporters,
some of whom are onscreen now. Joining my
Patreon or becoming a YouTube member are the
easiest ways to support me in making high-effort
videos about the commander format and beyond,
and I greatly appreciate all the direct support
I get. With that said, I’ll see you next week,
where I’ll be discussing tax evasion,
commander style. I’m coming for you Yuriko.